once in a blue moon maybe several times
in your career you'll embark on an
adventure where even from the minute you
start it you know that it's gonna be
something big
you know Wine Library TV launching
winelibrary.com
when I wrote crush it a speech or two
that I've given that plane video you
just know you're um embarking on
something that's gonna change the
outcome of your life and for me more
importantly change the outcome of so
many other people's lives when I started
the leb I just knew I knew that even I
think in episode one where I talked
about knowing and I mentioned the dirac
like it's so obvious to me what's gonna
happen daily being snapchat like our
execution these next twelve months it's
gonna be into me so [ __ ] crazy
what it all looks like a year from today
[Music]
you this was last Monday morning to
lunch
what's that I know man how you been good
yourself oh well yeah Darren yeah
remember how you doing good to see ya
yeah such a pleasure my solution thanks
for having me okay with us to discuss
the notion of marketing and the year we
lived in is the CEO of digital agency
vaynermedia thank you thank you so much
what I'm excited to talk about this
morning is deploying dramatic common
sense in a 20-17 world to an industry
that I've had an unbelievable time
getting to know I need a 70% of the
money maybe 50 but probably closer to 70
if you factor in the other channels
besides television but 50 percent of
that money is spent in the form of
making a 30-second video that 30-second
video in 2017 is deployed the following
way it plays in between television
linear television please go look back at
the last three revolutions industrial
revolutions they're people that got hurt
the most
look exactly like the people in this
room which was they were making behavior
for the prior game they were training
for basketball and the world made them
play hockey thank you
I'll just go around the introducer
different everybody right Wow like
you're gonna be mobbed out there ya know
like always you know hey hey doing Diego
Kai oh hey Brian how are you yeah I was
just very self-aware you know I talk a
lot about self-awareness
I just knew who I was and I really
genuinely you know I don't talk about
this a lot I genuinely believed that my
schooling career was gonna be my last
great vacation and so I kind of took
advantage of it that way and I thought I
could get a real head start and be
educated and you know I am scared to
think what would what I would have
looked like if the internet was around
[Music]
very meta watching and editing making
sure there's nothing wrong with the next
daily being Wow filming this one
my parents punished my mom punished me
for bad grades but she quietly created
an interesting framework of what I would
call light lines in the sand right
moveable lines in the sand she didn't
want me to be disrespectful or
completely punted and become a
degenerate but she absolutely gave me
the freedom to do my thing you know it's
funny I just dug up my report card in my
entire high school career got forays all
in gym you know so I was far from a
scalper and so yeah I think I think that
it was tough I went from being my own
boss making $800 a weekend $14 a weekend
to making 30 bucks a weekend bagging ice
for 15 hours a day in a liquor store but
at the same token I am I I just kind of
wanted to support my family's thing and
was willing to pay my dues and was
thankful for my parents coming to this
country even at that age knew that what
they did was special and wanted to
support our thing
that's this seed that makes everything
else you know I don't complain a lot
because I'm happy because things are
going well because I was self-aware and
I don't put myself in a position that
not succeed and I'm even self-aware
about the things that I do like trying
to bite off more than I could chew
extending myself you know but I'm
willing to pay the casualties were the
toll for those inefficiencies and those
shortcomings so you know above all our
self-awareness above all else man just
want to get together one of the main
things that I want to do is just to get
some time together as a group and do
that a little bit more often but I think
I think a couple things have emerged in
my mind we book this and even the
keynote I just gave it a a I think
really gives us some stuff to talk about
if you think over and Airbnb and all the
direct to consumer brands are gonna love
the subjectiveness of creative or the
horseshit reporting that has been
accepted within this ecosystem you were
out of your mind
you will never win if you play their
game if you play the game of the places
you came from against them to a client
we will lose so these are some of the
themes and things that I want to really
be talking out I want you to reframe
your thought process of never playing
their game I do not want to play your
[ __ ] this game we're gonna lose cuz
there is no truth to it
you have to understand there's no truth
to it whatever you need for me to
understand why we've got to get them
understand this is the television in a
world that this is now the television
and the television is the radio if you
understand that shift and you go read
the history of the transition of what
happened between the radio and the
television and all the quotes that the
television would never be a viable
medium compared to the radio or you
couldn't do the same creativity this is
just history repeating itself over and
over and over we're not social
we're not digital we're just attention
this is not about this is better than
that this is about if you were agnostic
if you were unemotional what's a better
deal than the other that really played a
today in the AAA confused the [ __ ] out
of people because they wanted to like
razz me but they're like buddies
that Super Bowl and he said creative was
the variable of success like I took you
know it's kind of like I think we don't
I did the 8-mile thing on them you know
like when you take away theirs they're
like [ __ ] I don't know how to rebuttal
it's absolutely heading in our direction
I think the key is to a spend some more
time together like this and we will be
letting good things continue to go more
high show cases and you know what you
got a fuckload so if somebody here wants
to be part of the ninja team to do
showcase use them that's what I got so
far I will say this there's always a
thing that is the generations thing ours
is Facebook video it's real big it's
[ __ ] it [ __ ] works thanks everybody
[Music]
are you
do I walk into the Internet okay okay
I'll see you in a little bit okay
bye-bye
you're not filming right that's what I'm
thinking that's what I'm thinking I'll
let you know
bye guys nothing to fancy today you know
Orlando in New York action obviously a
lot of passion for this becoming the
television and the television becoming
the radio that you're gonna focus in on
that on this one do I think we're in -
let me use this as a test-case for a
little bit of a different way of
storytelling kind of concise and
some random thoughts some stuff for the
library maybe not the first time I say
things but maybe the most Proust
pronounced but thanks for following the
journey guys
makes it fun how about that movie hour
and 30 minutes that movie though
[Music]
[Music]